so okay so welcome everyone
um to the simons institute uh
in the manner of speaking uh i'm chaffey
goldwasser i'm the director of the
institute and i see many many
familiar faces i think a lot of you have
been to
to berkeley i wish you could be here now
it's actually lovely weather
beautiful skies um and we are very
fortunate today to
uh have a very interesting workshop very
timely
that boss barack is actually going to uh
was
is put together and he's going i'm going
to hand it off to him in a minute
i just want to say a few things as you
saw there is gather town which we
gathered before and i think in some of
the breaks we will go there as well
and other than that because we are we
know each other
and i think that it would be a wonderful
thing that people want to sort of
show themselves they can turn off their
stop video button and show themselves
and similarly there's the
i think that boss maybe will go through
instructions more carefully
but there's the usual q a in chat uh
i think we would love it if people could
unmute themselves and ask questions
informally as well
in the spirit of the fact that we are
really kind of a tight-knit community
and this occasion is going to be uh to
talk about obfuscation so
i think it's very um the breakthroughs
of obfuscation of of late
i think it's very appropriate that boss
is going to start off the
the workshop because it's his work that
eventually was his thesis
um and many and some other authors uh
that started the whole question of how
to define obfuscation formally
and show that it was impossible so it is
kind of a fitting
that uh in this workshop we're actually
talking about the fact that
it seems like it is possible a according
to a different definition
so i'm going to hand it off to boss and
please buzz
introduce the do the real introduction
thank you thank you
is still there
well i can't hear anything i can't hear
buzz yet but okay so
i'll still the time tell you this the
usual thing that you should not bring
coffee cups into the
lecture room and yes or food
do it anyway i guess uh it's futile at
this point
buzz
okay um our videographer is
omid and i think he's on
line somewhere and ashley and jesse have
done
a wonderful job here on staff
uh among us for any problems
um we have a problem right now
that boss disappeared he's fixing his
status
he's fixing it that's a good point
we had a lot of premonitions there he
had the definition of eye obfuscation
which was later defined again in some
other form but uh actually
comes from there maybe we could even
provoke his phd right
we could revoke it yes it highlights
that the practical aspects of
obfuscation are still not worked out
you're saying that he's adding to the
follow-up works
section okay can can you guys hear me
now
yes you can okay so
yes somehow the there is never and
a zoom session without the technical
difficulties and
and so let me not waste more
much more of your time i i think yeah
i'm very grateful to the authors of
these works
that are uh that uh
came here and i think shafi alluded to
obfuscation has been sort of an
emotional whirlwind for our community
with a string of you know first negative
results then some positive some some
negative and
some some candidates some breaks and
this is a very loaded term in this
pandemic period but maybe we are
rounding the corner
and we see the light at the end of the
tunnel with obfuscation based on the
on a well-founded assumptions and maybe
even eventually
only basically only on lwe
and this is a in large part of the to
the works we'll hear
we'll hear about the in this workshop
so the other thing is that uh i hope
this workshop is going to be very
interactive so i encourage people that
want to participate
if you're right now listed as a
participant in the webinar rather than
as a panelist feel free to raise your
zoom hand
and we can promote you to a panelist
then you can
show your video and we would actually be
very happy if you do that because
we like to see people's faces and see
reactions
also uh plea if you have a question
during the talk you can
ask it during chat but also in i'll be
monitoring the chats but you can also
just
unmute yourself at the right point you
know when there is a natural break and
just ask the question
and i yes i hope we'll have a very
interactive and uh educational session
and
with that let me uh pass the button on
to uh
yeah or maybe we should wait three
minutes so we are
according to schedule so um
and yeah so i'm not going to do tons of
introductions
uh in the in this workshop i usually
don't like very lengthy introductions
but
yes our first speaker will be uh
who has worked in many areas of
cryptography obfuscation included
and then she's um
currently at a microsoft research in new
england
and also a an adjunct faculty member
at mit and yeah maybe you can
start by sharing your screen but we'll
wait
before we we actually start and maybe
i'll try to in the meantime figure out
my
own connection issues
does is
we don't understand see anything yet
oh okay it says you started screen
sharing but we don't see it
okay
yeah maybe if you haven't uh tried
exiting out and then trying it again
that is our own technician
so shafi what is the current operation
of this institute like in terms of
physical we were
actually just approved um a few days ago
for something called an outdoor pilot
which is you know we have boards around
it and we're putting some more boards
around the circumference of the building
and people can come and work there and
we're hopeful about an indoor as well
but now there's a lot down in california
so it's going to start in january 4.
we can see it now yale okay good
you can see full screen yep
great
[Music]
so just let me know if i can start at 30
please start
oh okay great so wow this is
uh exciting times uh so i'm going to
tell you
about kind of the journey that as a
community
we took uh towards program obfuscation
a i want to start by saying that this is
by no means a survey
actually this is more kind of a personal
take
on kind of this journey how i view it uh
you know i i'm sure there's going to be
a lot of amazing work that i'm
not going to reference i actually try to
kind of
uh i'm thinking of this talk also as a
state yeah
you can feel free to start talking if
i'm talking you can't hear me
i can hear you i can hear you yeah i can
hear you
also okay good so he's got some issues
so uh yes so uh
i'm thinking of this talk more as a
stage for kind of the workshop
uh kind of to give a perspective and
um first let me start by saying a huge
thank you
uh first for all the you know amazing
progress that everyone has made
but also particular thank you for all
the people who really helped me uh
prepare
this talk er schweitzwick rachel
rafael amit and vinod who i you know
constantly
begged with questions and got answers
and been you guys have been
uh superstars so thank you uh that was
great
i learned a lot from preparing this talk
so okay so
let's begin and so you know program
obfuscation
uh has been brought to our community uh
by the people of hada and barak ital who
defined it formally
and you know actually i want to say i'm
gonna
present this more as a kind of relating
all the work that has been done to kind
of what we learned from cryptography in
the past
so okay so what does the point of
program application we all know we want
to take
a program and convert it one that if we
look at it we see nothing it's
unintelligible
but still preserves the functionality
now how would we define it let's start
from the beginning you know we're
starting how would we define it well
you know we want to take let's say
circuit models a circuit that's typical
and we want to obfuscate it what do we
want to
preserve well we want to preserve the
functionality we want the obfuscator
that
generates an obfuscated circuit to be
efficient and we want the
obfuscated circuit to be hiding okay
what do we mean by hiding how do we
define hiding well you know
we all know how to define we've been
dealing with hiding
from the you know formal definitions
from the 80s you know we had the
definition of
zero knowledge in npc who kind of
introduced for us
the real ideal world definition so let's
take the real ideal world definition
here as well
what does it mean that whatever an
adversary can do
given an obfuscated program there's a
simulator
who can learn the same thing in the
ideal world okay what is the ideal world
here
well he gets input output access but
that's it
okay so whatever the adversary can now
can learn given an obfuscated program
the simulator can learn given only black
box access to the circuit
okay so that's natural however
this notion is noticed by these works
but by the work of bracketal
is impossible now actually this should
come with no surprise to anybody because
it's exactly the same impossibility
result that had for zero knowledge
so you know the original paper of gmr
wanted to use your knowledge you know
as classical proofs but they resort it
they change the model to interactive
proofs
to get a positive positive result they
realize that without interaction it's
impossible
essentially the same impossibility
result holds here why
the point is while the adversary gets
something in his hand
which is a succinct description which
the simulator does not
that's essentially what's going on here
that's what makes this notion impossible
now actually this is not as simple as
that the work of bakatal was very
complicated
and the reason is that uh they
restricted
uh the output of the adversary to be a
single bit
and once you restrict it to be a single
bit the impossibility result becomes
more complicated
but essentially it's still kind of this
idea
okay but because they restrict a single
bit it turns out that
you know they could only get a
possibility for a contrived
class of functions but soon after that
it was noticed
that actually if you allow auxiliary
information which we often do in
cryptography for example in
you know setting up zero knowledge then
it's actually impossible even for
natural
classes of functions okay so there's a
big impossibility result here
what do we do okay well there are
several options
we can take option number one is we know
because it will consider different
models
like uh was done in zero knowledge so
you know they consider interactive
proofs instead of non-interactive
so this was done actually we have
one-time programs we have obfuscation
with hardware and there's
you know probably other models and and
so on okay that's one option one
line with you know direction we took
another option is let's restrict
ourselves to very very simple functions
for which we don't have any negative
results like point function or
other subclasses of kind of evasive
functions
okay there's been a bunch of work in
this regime as well
and the third option which is going to
be the focus of this talk is let's
consider weaker definitions
and there were several definitions here
i wrote only two
but the focus of this talk is about
indistinguishability obfuscation
which is essentially the analog of
witness and distinguishability
in the context of obfuscation
plus do you have a question yes yes i'm
not sure if other participants but for
me
it seems like the screen is stuck on the
first slide but
i'm not sure if what's the case for
others
oh no the results
i i think i'm fine is there anybody that
has the same thing
as boys so they may be just my issue yes
okay mine is not as bad as boss but i'm
also a little behind like
uh i feel like you're talking maybe
uh half a minute ahead of the slides
i don't think so okay so i'll
i'll disconnect and reconnect and then
it might be just my issue
okay anybody else does everybody see
possible results on the slide and
does anybody else have this issue
because if many do then maybe i should
reconnect
no no it's fine no okay okay so
okay so the notion that work considering
that the focus of this work is
indistinguishability obfuscation
which is i said it's the analog of
witness and distinguishable proofs
and actually you know it's not that
surprising that we don't have negative
results here
exactly as we have non-interactive wi
why not have you know
indistinguishability obfuscation
it's very analogous okay so what is the
definition of a distinguishability
obfuscation
it was this definition was again the
seminal work
uh was proposed and it's as i said then
now the analogy of witness and
distinguishability it just says
any two circuits that are equivalent
uh have the same input output behavior
you should not be able to distinguish
between obfuscation
of one and obfuscation of the other
okay exactly as you should not be able
to distinguish between
a wi proof of one witness and a wi proof
of another
okay so why is this an interesting up
notion well it was shown uh by uh
goldwater
actually in some sense it's the best
possible for skater so that's good you
know if you want something this is the
best you can hope for
and again analogous to knee we proof
which is kind of aniway proof you can
think of as a witness that reveals kind
of the minimal amount of information
so it's kind of analogous here too uh of
course
it's the let me quantify it's the best
possible obfuscation among
all obfuscation of a certain size that
are slightly smaller than this so
there's the quantification but
essentially it's a great opposite
it's the best possible in a sense
however at that point which is 2007
it was still not clear to us what what
is it good for
and you know we kind of this in some
sense i i felt at least that this notion
was a bit dismissed
which is surprising because we should
know better you know we saw how
wi has been so influential you know this
should be two in a sense but
we didn't kind of understand it or at
least
you know uh talked about it in this way
okay so indeed from 2001 from the point
this notion
was put forth until 2013 we had actually
in general for obfuscation
we had no constructions i o and
distribution obfuscation
known possibility results and actually
no motivations even
you know if you look at these papers
they say well it's not clear they don't
hide not the word it's interesting for
you know we were very skeptical uh
and you know one thing that kind of is
interesting to me
is that you know we didn't have any
heuristics even though
obfuscators were used in practice
and so usually it's the opposite you
know usually we have
we're kind of they're doing things kind
of behind us and we're ahead but this
time they were ahead of us we had no
uh you know heuristics and i remember
when i
interviewed it was when i after my phd
when i interviewed like microsoft and
ibm
and i asked them so how do you do it you
know we have no idea
so what's your what's your secret and i
got very interesting answers like well
you know we remove the comments we
rename variables we add junk code so
they really did it in a very very
kind of um i don't know basic way they
also didn't have very sophisticated
tools
okay so this all was the case until the
breakthrough result of 2013
by gag gentry jalebirikova sahin waters
who gave the first
candidate construction of obfuscation
okay
and of course they called it candy
construction of indistinguishability
obfuscation because
of course we know vbb doesn't exist so
you know it's a candidate for
indistinguishability application
okay and soon after this candidate was
put forth
all the uh high waters came up with a
beautiful puncturing technique
that shows that io is actually very
useful
and this brought up to this kind of land
of apostopia
uh thank you daniel for the slide uh
which
uh says that wow if you we have io we
have
all these amazing things crypto world is
beautiful
okay all these main amazing primitives
so now though the only question remain
do we actually have it or not because
the original construction
the candidate construction did not come
with a proof
so it was a heuristic and it was not
clear whether this heuristic is indeed
secure or not
by the way please please talk me with
questions at any point of course
as buzz said okay
so i wanna talk a little about a little
bit about this
first i o heuristic but i'm gonna i'm
not sure i'm
i'm gonna explain it in a way that is
really truthful to the paper i'm gonna
more explain in the way i view
the intentions of that paper so uh and
maybe from a perspective of several
years later
so here's kind of the the their idea i
think
you know the first observation is look
fhe fully homomorphic encryption
is actually a great applicator it hides
everything but unfortunately
it also hides the output so that's not
good
but then the idea is well all we need is
to obfuscate the decryption function
in some sense so we can do an fhe and we
just need a decryption of of an
application of
the decryption functions now this is a
bit over
simplified because if i just give you uh
obfuscation of the decryption you'll
just
decrypt the circuit see that i encrypt
it for you it won't
hide but for simplicity now let's think
i
suppose i give you a decryption function
that only
decrypts for you valid cipher text that
we're computing by evaluating this
circuit c just as a simplification
now the next observation was well if
this decryption
was degree 2 then actually we can get
the output in the clear
and the reason we can get output in the
clear is the following
well if it was a degree two over
uh uh when the computation is over
a module a large prime p and the secret
key was random
in zp uh to the end let's say and then
what we could do
is we can take a bilinear a a group with
bilinear maps
and give u as an obfuscation g to this
power of the secret key
so g to the z uh sk1 sk2 up to skn
and because we have pairings you know we
can do degree two
uh uh computation the in the exponent
and we can test zero that's kind of the
idea the idea is we can zero test
so we can check degree two functions we
can check if the output is decrypted to
zero or not
so that's great but of course decryption
functions are not degree two
uh they're actually high degree and so
the idea was you know
we don't have uh you know we can't use
bilinear map let's use multilinear maps
so what is a multilinear map is it's the
same thing as a bilinear but
multi so it takes uh groups g1 up to gn
and takes g1 to the x1 up to g to the x
n
to a an element in the
in the in some target group e to the g 1
up to g
n to the power of the multiplication of
the x i's
so it's just an analogous of uh to
bilinear maps it's an extension
so so uh so that idea
but of course this simple outline
doesn't work for many reasons
and in particular the if you do it this
way the decryption
function does not just require
multi-linear maps
that are good for polynomial degree
you'll need exponential degree
so that doesn't work and so their actual
construction is more complicated they
actually go through
barrington's theorem and they need to
use kind of the re-randomization
technique of
of killian to hide things and so things
are more complicated
but i think in my opinion the high level
kind of the simplified version is this
okay so one thing i want to point out
yes that's a very cool way to look at it
i've not seen it before i wonder
are there actually encryptions where the
degree is where you could kind of use
this
at least for heuristic directly where
the degree is not
exponential but polynomial
i so i'm not sure i don't think so
because i think if the degree was
polynomial it would be essentially an
evasive function
it will correspond to an evasive
function because if a degree is
polynomial it has only polynomially many
non-zero a elements
so it's it's uh polynomially many zeros
uh so i think a linear map right so
it has many variables right it has n
variables but could be low degree
right could even be multilinear but i i
still don't know a good way of doing it
though
what did you think of the gth uh sw
construction itself as providing such an
encryption scheme
where the question is harrington and
killian yeah
that's a nice way to encapsulate it
yeah okay so then the
so one thing i want to point out it
seemed you know when
you know that oh degree two it's
impossible you can't have a
decryption of degree two but actually
surprisingly
the you know breakthrough the result
that we're gonna see today
by a ayush rachel and amit
actually does go through this round they
don't quite achieve degree two because
that but
they do this degree 2.5 which they'll
talk about so actually this kind of
route did actually
uh span out pretty well but that was
later uh you know in the beginning
we said okay clearly we need multilinear
maps and now the question
is where the hell do we get these and
then there started a quest to
you know get heuristics of multilinear
maps
was there a question yeah so i
just wanted to point out i think that
the combination of low degree and
huge models that that's the hard part
smaller than the degree then you could
get like the greater
things are hard over the binary field of
small fields
so precisely i think that's exactly the
issue
the fact that the modulus p needs to be
huge and the the gap
between the degree and the modulus i
think is the issue
and and maybe we can also mention that
just in terms of history
the multilinear maps came first and the
a heuristic after
exactly so that's exactly that's my next
point yes
so actually the uh the multi them
there were already in 2012 by gang
gently haley they gave the first
heuristic
construction of not the perfect
multi-linear map that i showed but a
noisy version of that
and the version of this was used by this
first i o heuristic
uh okay so so you know
there was this idea of using multilinear
maps there's been a lot of work on it
from 2013 till today and
here's my view and and where we are so
first
even today we don't have any clean
multi-linear map except for
degree two by linear that's first now in
terms of noisy ones we have a bunch
uh but all of them seem to have very
serious breaks
and you know the history was okay
there's a
break and then it breaks the
construction so there's another
construction
and then there's a another break to the
multi-linear map and then
which causes a break to the i o
construction and another and there's
been kind of a bunch of constructions
uh by the way all these breaks are some
form of
linearization attacks and at the end
i think there's only a couple works i
think these two works
uh that are not known to be broken
they're using uh what's called a weak
multilinear maps now i wish i can tell
you more about them
but as soon as i try to look at it i
realized
it's really complicated and my kind of
instinct was just to run away
so i'm not gonna tell you more about
these but
uh but the point is these are not broken
at least not yet we don't know that
they're broken
okay so where are we so far so here's
the
you know the state of the art we had
candidate constructions which is
wonderful
actually we could particip partition
them to kind of groups
they were the first generation that
relied on
multi-linear maps of high degree
polynomial degree and then there was an
effort to reduce reduce reduce the
degree
the second generation were the constant
degree relied needed constant degree
multilinear maps
but all of these use this messy
cryptographic assumption
of kind of use noisy multilingual maps
and i personally find it very messy and
i need a cleaner you know world but then
there was the third generation
and oh i think it's probably worth
mentioning to people
who were not part of these papers that
the degree of the multilingual map had
something to do with the complexity of
the program
so that this is a big jump from
generation one to two
yes yes so uh yeah yes exactly i mean
yes
uh right so the generation uh
uh two kind of got rid of uh uh they
they kind of managed to talk they
realized i'm gonna get to it
that all you need to do is essentially
consider nc0
uh computations which are constant
degree
so there is a jump there uh yes
and then uh thank you jeffy by the way
please uh stop me and feel free to
inject
you know perspectives here okay because
the point is uh uh
you know for the community to learn
about it if you have anything that uh
uh add please do uh
okay then the third generation actually
went back
they realized oh okay you know the
multilingual maps are messy
let's try to go back and use uh bilinear
maps
and uh but and so so these use kind
these are the new ones you see
2019 up to 20. but even these
the state of the art was that they're
not so even these are not under standard
assumptions
um and they were constantly the state of
the art was there's an attack
and a fix and an attack and a fix and it
was kind of um
i don't know between a comedy and a
tragedy so a
like i remember once i was in a pc of a
stock or fox was it
and there were a bunch of papers that
did all these amazing things under io
it was right after the beautiful paper
of uh sahain waters who proposed the
puncturing technique and it was
like these beautiful works that use this
this technique to get all these amazing
cryptograph all these amazing uh uh
notions and we were in the committee and
we're like but do i
exist yes next day no next day yes next
day no and i remember that
you know at some point the people you
know the cryptographers from the outside
were like
is this a joke yesterday they didn't
exist today they do exist
like yeah well they fixed you know but
it was really a funny uh
a a bit frustrating i'm sure for the
people who actually had their schemes uh
you know broken fixed it was
uh you know a roller coaster
uh and i think it's a working experience
i just really want to
this is you know it was a great learning
experience
every attack gave us new insight into
what was needed so just wanted to
mention that
yeah actually uh i mean i want to
elaborate on that
which is i think we learned a lot of
lessons from this journey
and one of the lessons is that
actually um you know
relying on maybe having
weaknesses in your scheme or breaks or
it's not a bad thing it still
moves signs forward the question is are
there good ideas there
and all these things kind of you know i
my opinion of this journey is that it's
actually
uh it's um it's a journey of the
community
and you know uh who put the final stone
is is uh you know it's that's not the
point the point is each kind of
everyone kind of put a brick and each
idea
led to the other and i think it's kind
of beautiful to see kind of
how how things how uh this effort
uh uh evolved uh but i agree completely
i also like to interject i think one of
the main
reasons why i think in generation three
possibly we made progress
is that uh we
at least there was a very clear notion
of
what it means to break so uh
when the standard was here is a
heuristic i o construction
takes it as a whole and as long as you
don't break i o fully you have not made
any progress it's very hard to make
scientific progress
when you say okay i have reduced io to
four discrete assumptions and here is
the one magical one where i need the
pseudo random generators of a very
particular
type you you actually the assumption is
well specified enough so people can
break it and now you can make progress
and and i think this is a lesson we
learned a lot of the time in in
cryptography that we when we want to
make um
if we want this attack fix uh type of
cycle to get us forward rather than
running in circles we really want
precise definitions and precise meaning
of what it means
to be broken completely completely agree
uh yeah so so after this i felt like uh
at least for me
uh i felt like okay i need to run away
from this this is
you know this is really crazy uh
but what i want to show you in this uh
talk
is actually it's not as messy and uh
scary and as it seems and i want to show
you kind of how as a community
there was an effort a really beautiful
effort to reduce
you know the problem value which seems
very difficult
to easier and easier problems and the
new beautiful result that we're going to
hear about today used this progress
so in particular the first thing that
was observed is actually
to construct io it suffices to construct
functional encryption succinct
functional encryption
with sub-exponential security that was
the first observation
by anant and jane and betanski
then it was observed by lean pass set in
telang
that actually you don't need full
succinctness of the fee
it's enough to have semi-succinctness
and i'll explain what that is
if you're also willing to assume lwe
and then it was this and then it was
noticed actually you don't need full fe
all you need is for nc zero so for
constant uh
a for for um for nc zero assuming you
have also prg for zero
great then it was as shown
actually even that you all you need is
this xio
which i'll explain a sub-exponential
version of it and very very recently
this year was shown it was actually
um formalized in an even simpler way
by the means of functional encoding and
what we're going to see in this workshop
is
the first uh today we're going to see
the result of
jane lynn and sahai uh i use rachel and
amit
who are going to show how they how to
construct
this semi-sexing fe for nc 0
well-founded assumptions uh uh
what i think is actually pretty standard
assumptions
and tomorrow we're gonna see uh the
works actually there's two works
of brockelskittle and gaypas
that show how to construct uh
io how to control this functional
encoding and then
get i o this way uh and uh
yeah the functional encoding is kind of
a new these kind of the things we're
going to see tomorrow
are new they're not under like
well-established assumptions yet in my
opinion
but it's a very very excited exciting
line of work that i
i really think they're going to you know
i'm optimistic that they'll be able to
uh improve on it and get uh better
um better assumptions so i find it very
exciting
okay so let me start so that's my plan
for today to kind of show you this
uh a this would these reductions
i think they're based on very
interesting ideas so any questions
before i start
no okay so one thing i want to point out
that these reductions are actually based
on ideas that we all knew in
cryptography already it's really
interesting to see how it evolved
so this this line of work the main thing
it shows us
is that all we need in order to get io
is some form of compression
that's the bottom line if we can
compress a little bit we're good
and at first this is pretty obvious
i mean in some level why look we know
that you know garbled circuits for
example
is a great obfuscator but it's only for
a single computation
so if you know the circuit you know one
input a garble circuit
hides everything that's great but it's
just one computation
what io does is it essentially needs to
protect not just one computation
but exponentially many like for all the
possible inputs
and it needs to do it kind of in a
compressing way i mean you can
you know send exponentially many garbled
circuits that'd be good but it's too
much of course
so um so we need some we need to go kind
of from
protecting a single computation to
protecting exponentially many
computations
now if we just think about this for a
second
it's pretty clear that wait this was
done before this is exactly what ggm did
right what is pseudorandom function it
says well you know we can generate a
little bit of randomness
how do we generate exponentially manual
randomness using prg
using prf so random functions
this is a this kind of seems very very
similar
and indeed this was the idea behind
going from
succinct functional encryption to i o
it's exactly kind of using
the ggn idea so
let me just recall or say what a
functional
encryption is so a function encryption
is a semantically
we'll talk about for now public key
functional encryption
so it's a semantically secure semantic
secure encryption
such that for any function
we can generate a function key
so given the secret key of the
encryption
and given a function let's say from l
bits to m bits
we can efficiently generate a secret key
sub f
a secret key from this f and what the
secret key allows us to do
is it essentially breaks a little bit in
a very specific way the
semantic security what it allows us to
do
is given an encryption of x and secret
key of f
it allows us to compute f of x in the
clear efficiently
but that's all so uh
so more specifically the succinctless
requirement
first is that the run time and the
output length
of the encryption it can actually depend
on the number of output bits of f but
in a a little bit of shrinking way so it
should be at most let's say n to the one
minus epsilon for any constant epsilon
you want
okay so so the first so again we have
one fixed f
that outputs m bits we allow the
encryption to depend on m but needs to
be sublinear in m
so the runtime and the output length of
the encryption needs to be sublinear
uh m to the one minus epsilon and the
security
says well there are many variants but
the one that's relevant here
it says that if you're given a function
key
secret key sub f then still semantically
semantic security holds so you can't
distinguish an encryption of x
encryption of x prime
so long as f of x is equal to f of x
prime
so of course you learn f of x but that's
the only thing you learn other than that
they're distinguishable
okay so
okay so uh just one point
is actually if the succinct was
a little less succinct and we allow
let's say
the encryption to output m bits instead
of
m to the one minus epsilon we we have
that under lwe
okay and that's from joint work with uh
uh
so it seems like what we have from lwe
so all we need is like this tiny epsilon
there to get it
uh to imply io that's what i'm gonna
show you why it implies io
and and now it's it's interesting kind
of to think so is it
is it close to lw or is it close to io
you know is it
what's going on here and actually it was
interesting i looked at the paper of
bhitan skin by kuntanatan and it was
interesting to see how
we thought back then so i think so let
me just quote uh
what they said so it is rather tempting
to be pessimistic
and to interpret our result as a lower
bound showing that improving
functional encryption based on standard
assumptions may be very hard
or perhaps straight out impossible
our take and the result is quite
optimistic
we hope that the construction would
eventually lead to io for more standard
assumptions
which it indeed uh did at the end but
it's interesting to see how we were so
pessimistic about io
at the time and one thing i want to
point out is
fe seems indeed significantly weaker
than i o and the reason that it's
significantly weaker
in my opinion is that for to construct
io
in some sense you need to inject kind of
randomness
in one shot and protect exponentially
many computations
in one shot whereas in fe
you can inject randomness kind of for
each computation
like for every encryption of x you
inject more randomness
so it seems much much uh easier
um yeah and let me think here uh neil
bitansky
who walked me through explaining to me
their paper really nicely so
uh so it's his kind of motivation
and uh hey and explanation
okay so how do you go from fe
to io so it's really the idea is ggm
what we need to do is kind of recycle
randomness exactly as was done in ggm
and their construction is very similar
so here's how here's in a nutshell here
is their i o construction
so their obfuscation actually uh
consists of you first encrypt you have a
functional encryption i'm going to
construct an i o
so the i o first consists of encryption
of the circuit you want to obfuscate
but there and more things then some
function keys so let me tell you what
these function keys are
they consider this tree where each node
of the tree is labeled
by an encryption a function like the
encryption of the functional encryption
of the circuit c and some prefixes
inputs
x 1 up to x i and this prefix depends
kind of on the
path so and the children
of this node are going to be again the
prefix with the zero
and the prefix with one so kind of the
prefix
grows grows grows until you get to the
leaf and
each leaf is labeled by encryption of x
of c and an input x one of x n
suppose the circuit you want to
obfuscate has n bits
okay so this is the tree now what are
the stick
what are the function keys that a we
give
so each function key we give essentially
n function keys
kind of one function for for each layer
of this
uh exponential size a tree
and the function what it does is given c
and the prefix it computes the
encryption
of of the children it essentially
computes the label of the children
so the encryption of c x one up to x i
was zero
and the encryption of x one up to x i
with one
that's essentially uh the idea
and and so given these function keys you
can compute essentially
all the labels in the tree so you can in
particular compute
any label and any label of the leaf
and what they also give the secret key
for the universal circuit
then input c and x output c of x
so that's how you get everything so
that's the high level idea
of course one needs to be very careful
for example
this function outputs a cipher text so
there's randomness going on so they need
to deal with randomness
and so on so forth but this pretty kind
of use standard
the one thing that's important is that
the inc for this
construction not to blow up you know for
the you want to make sure that the
you know the cipher text at the top are
not huge
that's why you need to ensure that the
length of a cipher text does not grow
with m with the output of the function
which is now two ciphertexts
and you want to make sure the runtime
also doesn't explode otherwise your
obfuscated circuit will run in
exponential time so one needs to be
careful when implementing it and that's
why they need
kind of the sexiness of that fee that
the run time and the output length
doesn't grow
with the output of the function okay but
that's kind of the general idea which
it's really nice and it's really got
kind of based on the ggm
idea okay
uh later soon after uh
yes vinnie so if you get the minor
comparison like m of a body log m or
something like this
what do you get do you get something uh
no i think um
well you won't get uh like
you may get something but i mean the
obfuscation will be too big whether it's
gonna be
no i don't think you i think if you get
m over
let's see one second hey
yeah i i think i think uh things will
blow up too fast and probably be
exponential
is my guess but i didn't actually check
one needs to do you know uh
to check the calculations i don't know
if you know i think
sorry to interrupt i think that even if
it's one bit smaller
what you could do is make it output one
cypher text then output one extra bit of
the next ciphertext i think even one bit
smaller would be good
right again sorry you're saying if you
have one bit smaller oh you you won't
output two you'll just output one
i will one output one ciphertext and one
bit of something
another ciphertext and i can collect one
bit along the way
i see i see i see i see so you just make
it more complex
yeah nice okay nice nice okay very nice
eh okay good hey thanks uh
great okay so that for that you need uh
succeedness
a but then it was shown that actually
semi-succinct is enough if you also have
lwe
so let me tell you what semi-sex
thickness is so remember with succinate
we said we need the runtime
and the output length to be smaller than
m semi-succinct said oh forget about
runtime
only cares about the length so the
encryption can run in time n
or poly m but the output needs to be
smaller than m okay
so okay so that's that's what semi-sex
sickness is so
in some sense uh the way to think about
it is existence requires
that the cipher text are short and the
encryption is fast both of them
are smaller than m whereas semi-sex
weakness says
the cipher text is short but the
encryption can be long
okay a so how do they get that
the way they go so they essentially
shall use a function uh
short but slow functional encryption to
get short and fast functional encryption
and the way they do that is essentially
they use the gkpvz result
which gives you as i said a functional
encryption which is
not something they're not so it's both
the runtime and the output length are
proportional to m
and i essentially if you plug that
instead so the main idea is essentially
you know they give you you have a slow
encrypt you need a fast encryption
how do you get a fast encryption well
you use
the encryption of the gk pvz
a you see my mouse by the way hovering
or no yes okay great so uh you use
instead of using the slow encryption
you use the encryption uh uh from gkpvc
uh to compute the slow encryption for
you and the point is
that the output here to compute the slow
encryption the slow encryption is
actually short
so the output length is small because
you're computing a short encryption
so the basic idea is just a composition
they
take their short and slow encryption
compose it with gk pvz
and they get the success so that's
basically it
so okay so now semi-six signal is enough
that's great
the next observation actually all you
need is semi-sex sickness
for nc zero you don't need to consider
anything else
why is instantly zero enough
this should again immediately ring a
bell
well we have randomized encodings that
show that actually
you know you can uh you can convert any
function to 1 in nc 0 by considering the
randomize encoding of this function
which is essentially how they get how
they show that
fe for nc 0 suffices so all these kind
of things are using things that we
already knew
you know it's very kind of uh basic in
some sense
okay so nc0 is all we need great and
then
uh lean past it and telling show that
actually
they formalized it in a different way of
exile
so let me tell you what an xio is
because i think it's very interesting
xio really kind of captures the fact
that forget about
fe with encryption decryption forget
about all that really all you need is
compression
and this was formalized really nicely in
this xio
so what does the xio say it says look
all we need is an io
for a circuit that takes only polynomial
many inputs forget about this
exponential many inputs and so on
it takes n inputs like 1 to n where
think of n is polynomial
and all you want is the size of the
obfuscated circuit
to not just be the truth table to be
slightly better than true stable
so of course you can output the truth
table that's in a good obfuscation
uh but uh that's you know very
non-succinct as long as you can
get an obfuscation of size n to the one
minus epsilon
you're good and moreover this io can be
generated in a long time
polyen so the time to generate it
doesn't need to be succeed
you can actually run the c for all the
inputs and so on no succinctly is there
just some thickness of the kind of
representation
so this really captures kind of the
intuition that i
said before that i to get io really why
you need a succinct that's all
and to see why xio implies the
semi-succinct fe
this is actually the only density zero
here it just applies uh
some assets in fe again goes through the
gkpvz result
and the idea is to say the following
look we already have
fe but it's not succinct okay
uh the fe of gk pvc has encryption
length n
we need encryption length the
semi-succinct says we need an encryption
length of
n to the one minus epsilon so really
what we need to do here
is compress the encryption a little bit
how do we compress the encryption a
little bit oh xio
this is exactly what xo does it
compresses a little bit
so essentially the way they construct
their they're actually the semi-succinct
fe
is their new encryption is not the
encryption
the exact encryption of gkpvz but
actually
they their encryption is xio
that outputs the encryption of jk pvz
which i denote by encryption lw because
the
gkpv is based on lwe
so again the way they get show that xio
implies fe is by using the gkpvz result
so this is remarkable that all we need
is you know tiny bit of compression
and finally in this year there's been a
really amazing uh line of work
started with burkelski dotlin
in their first paper and then after that
uh following by gay pass and win wicks
and also by berkeley tal who
later improved as well and they showed
essentially that all we need
is well what original was called split
fhe uh
but what now i i think of it more as a
functional
encoding that's i think the term from we
wix
uh but essentially what they say is
forget about the exact definition of
functional quoting but here's
essentially let me kind of
tell you how they propose to construct
xio
they say you know what the way i'm going
to construct xio is i'm going to give
some
encoding of the circuit that's the
functional coding so this is an encoding
of the circuit
with some randomness this encoding
should hide the circuit
and i'm going to give you this hint that
will allow you to compute the circuit on
c1 up to cn
uh and this hint depends on the
randomness
and the succinct okay so the hint should
be of length
n to the one minus epsilon so this is
kind of the
idea of functional coding you encode the
circuit
and you give a hint related to the
randomness that allows you to do the
computation
uh in a way that reveals c1 up to cn and
nothing more
okay so uh and their main observation
i mean their observation so they
construct this functional encryption but
their main observation that allowed them
to construct this functional encryption
was the realization that actually all
they needed to construct this functional
encryption in the crs model
where the crs can be big it can be as
big as n
and the reason that you can construct a
c you can use a crs is because
okay just put a crs on everything go all
the way up with the crs
and io with the crs is just essentially
at some point
the crs is small enough it's just and it
goes away
so uh it can be part of the i o at some
point
okay so that's kind of uh
uh of course there were many more in the
way of reductions and so on there's some
reduction to
secret kia fe and so i'm not kind as i
said it's not a survey i'm kind of
uh giving the results that i think are
are necessary to
see the progression that we're going to
see in this workshop and indeed
what we're going to see that jamilyn
sahi as i said
will show how to construct uh a succinct
fe
for nc 0 and the results we're going to
see tomorrow are going to construct
dysfunctional encodings which will imply
io
you really can ask a couple questions on
your style of course yes
but i mean um we didn't talk about the
pseudorandom
generator for nc 0. i'm going to talk
about that in the next slide
oh okay and another thing is that
you when you say sub-exponential here
what does that refer to in the xio that
refers to the compression
yeah so let me tell you where the f the
x actually the sub exponential
uh comes from uh the sorry
uh comes from the work of of uh you know
the
for fe here you need subexponential uh
and therefore kind of the sub
exponential kind of
triggers down uh and the reason you need
sub-exponential is if you remember
there's kind of this gigantic circuit
the
there's this tree and um
in the reduction when you do the
reduction you need to pay with this kind
of
size of the tree essentially uh so
so you can only break something that has
that yeah
the time to break essentially requires
going over
kind of a tree so i don't have a better
explanation i don't know if anybody in
the audience here
uh has one but essentially that's how i
think of it
this is a hybrid argument with an
exponential number of steps
yeah the probability needs to be sub
exponential to
make that work right i i just want to
add
that it's different from the setting the
ggm for prf because in prf that the
cluster
engages in an interactive game where
adversary submits the inputs it wants to
get
the prf output for so in some sense then
the proof can focus on those
polynomially many inputs
when you do the reaction and hence
polynomial
then do the hybrid for only a polynomial
number of inputs
but i know there is no interactive games
that you just give the entire class in
the program to the cursory
and you have no idea that what inputs
this person is going to evaluate on
so hence we just hybrid over all
possible inputs
so it's in not necessarily inherent but
it's inherent with these type of
techniques
it's inherent with the technique yes
yeah
yeah it feels a bit more inherent than
that but i don't have more to say
about it i guess i'll add that
for several applications you can avoid
that so sometimes you don't have to do
exponentially many hybrids for the
specimen
yeah thanks sanjim that's a good point
uh so you know there's all these results
that say i o implies this and i imply
that
many times just succinct fe already
imply and you don't need the exponent
sub
you don't need the sub exponentially
there if you go just directly
so i think that's a good point
okay so in the last two minutes i have
left i want to focus a little bit
on and this chaffee goes to the prg uh
to talk about
how we use how we get uh obfuscation io
uh how we get essentially this
functional encryption for nc zero
because there's a line of work it's not
uh you know jls is not the first one
there's been a lot of work in this
uh direction and i want to kind of just
summarize uh where what this work is
so remember we need to get semi-16 fe
for nc
0. and here's the idea the original idea
actually
started from uh jvw gobonovich
and then used in gkpvc uh that shows
that
actually so it's enough to construct
functional encryption
for the decryption uh uh circuit so let
me explain
here's the functional encryption the
functional encryption you
how do you encrypt x you give an fhg of
x
and you give one function key the
function key essentially
if you want to allow to compute x and
input c
what you do is you give a function that
depends on
c and the decryption of the fhe
essentially this function what it does
it publicly computes
c on the encrypted x and then secretly
kind of decrypts the outcome
and uh and what was noticed actually
before even sorry
uh what was the the point of gvw they
said
actually all we care about is the degree
of the secret decryption
the public part the fact that you you
know you need to do to compute
c and the f g of x we don't
we don't need to keep that secret that's
public it's they called it um
partially hiding uh i think it was then
predicate encryption of the
tier was actually way before the
predicate encryption but essentially all
we care about is the degree
of the decryption moreover what they
noticed in
2015 actually the degree is almost
linear
what is it what how do you decrypt it's
essentially inner product with the
secret key
and you get a noise the output that's
amazing so it's not
not a high degree linear for you
wonderful the problem is
that you get a noisy output but this
noise is sensitive
you can't just output the noise output
because this noise
is a function of the randomness used to
encrypt x and if you
reveal this randomness things are broken
so this noise needs to be hidden you
can't just output it and that's where
the problem begins
okay so in this line of work so actually
in gk pvz the way we did it
is we got rid of the noise by kind of
rounding it away using garbled circuit
but then we didn't get succinctness so
the idea here in order to get
succinctness was
they said smudge the noise and the idea
of smudging
i think dates originally to actually
gentry it's been uh
in his thesis but maybe even before uh
in one of his papers
um so uh here's what the idea the idea
encrypts not only x but randomness
and this randomness is going to be used
to kind of
smudge the secret noise so when you
output you don't just output
the output with the secret noise but you
output the output with the secret noise
but smudged with this random noise
and you know it will statistically hide
the secret noise
so and it was used already in the
context of obfuscation by aguero rosen
in follow-up works
okay so great so so let's smudge the
noise great what is the problem
the problem that this smudge noise r
is too long we won't get thickness
anymore it's good it works
but it's not going to be succinct
because the noise is that length
of the output which is exactly what
we're trying to shrink
so it won't give you succinctness so
here comes the prg use a prg
great great idea we have prg's but we
need degree two
the reason we need degree two uh we can
have high degree but then you'll be
multi-lingual your maps if you wanna use
bi-linear maps
you need degree two okay and that's a
problem we don't have degree two
and then there's been a bunch of
attempts to construct well we know we
can't conservatively two
prgs but some pseudorandom objects
and these have been broken and fixed and
that's kind of the
third generation of the uh
you know construction that we mentioned
in the beginning
a actually i want to mention
interestingly they were broken via some
of squares algorithm which is kind of
uh interesting uh interesting connection
there
a and so the new idea in the
breakthrough result of jls that you'll
see today
is how to construct this prg not quite
degree two
rather what they call degree 2.5 but
essentially sufficient to
base it on bilinear from lpn learning
parity
with noise uh with some the regime of
parameters that they'll explain
and prg's in nc 0. so that's kind of uh
i think the focus of the jls is on this
on this prg
so this is a beautiful beautiful
beautiful line of work
let me just summarize because i'm out of
time uh so
we saw this progression as i said
uh you know we'll see today the jls
construction based on well-founded
assumption
tomorrow we'll see the construction
based on functional encodings
uh one thing i want to say these results
are still kind of have this uh
a circular security a
type definition which or assumption
which is not standard yet
or is not standard period for us uh but
i think
this ideas are in their infancy and
they're very interesting and uh you know
it's it's very exciting
progress that may lead to actually i o
under
lwe so these results rely on lattices
they don't use any bilinear
any mappings at all so you know they may
be quantum secure for example
and may lead to interesting follow-ups
so i just want to end
by congratulating all the
amazing people who had wonderful
wonderful results and moreover
congratulate the entire community
for for kind of stepping in and
achieving this i think it's been a
wonderful wonderful journey
and a very exciting one okay thank you
[Applause]
questions or maybe i should stop sharing
this was really an amazing talk thank
you
you managed to compress
in the spirit of compression you managed
to compress
dozens of papers into a very in an
excellent
observation and an excellent overview
and
and yes
people can feel free to ask questions
and i'll try to
i'll try to troubleshoot my internet in
four minutes
a minute will start okay
okay so could i go for an informal
question
at this time sure so that that doesn't
seem
like an easy journey at all and i could
even say that only from your facial
expressions
that was really energetic so i've been
wondering
how do you know you are not wasting your
time when you are working on
an unwell established approach good i
have i
approached with seems rescued so i i
want to say something about that's a
great question
how do you know that you're not wasting
your time if you don't get the results
you want
and i'll tell you what i feel like is
what's not waste of time
so first if you feel like you're making
progress and you're understanding that's
not waste of time
even if you didn't get any to where you
want your end goal it's not a waste of
time
okay you understand more that's very
valuable
moreover if you have a good idea
even if it doesn't work a good idea is
valuable
and it's we saw this here over and over
again there were great ideas that were
broken
they were still extremely valuable so as
long as you feel like your
understanding is improving and new ideas
are coming
whether they work or don't work it's
valuable
because at the end you know pieces come
together that's my
my opinion but i'm happy to let others
uh inject their own opinions
i have a technical question and then
leave your remark on that but
uh in the q a you said uh regarding
exponential loss another way to look at
it
is that the reduction must know y c zero
c one are functioning equivalent
which seems to require going over all
the two to the n inputs
so i guess my question here is why does
the reduction have to know that
and second of all um in that case it
should it wouldn't be sub-exponential it
would be
exponential so so it won't be
exponential because you can play with
the
with the security parameter so you go
over all the inputs n
two to the n but you make the security
parameter enter the thousand and then
enter the epsilon so it becomes a
sub exponential not exponential why
do they have why do we have to check
that they're function equivalent
if i break something at the end i break
it right sorry so i didn't
let me i didn't read the uh maybe i can
just say something that that
you know the i o only requires security
and we can only hope for security when
the circuits are functionally equivalent
right also okay that must be used
somewhere in the argument
right the point is that in your security
proof you better be using
that c0 and c1r equivalent otherwise
your proof can't possibly work because
you're proving too much
but the reduction is that if somebody
so there is an obfuscation okay let's
say you claim that you have a
construction
and it works when the circuits are
equivalent and somebody comes along and
he breaks it
uh
i mean
it's actually a really great question
that you're asking because this has been
an intuition
that me and sanjim and many many people
throughout the community and i think
what i can like have discussed
yet we've never been able to exactly
formalize it
because of this issue so at least as far
as i know
no one has been able to completely
formalize this need for
um for an explorer you know an
exponential number of steps in the
in the in the in the uh
so it's more like a moral argument as
opposed to a real argument the question
is
how would it work you know like how
could it how could you make use of a
breaker
if you don't even know why the circuits
are equivalent it's just
more of like a moral argument that i
don't know how to write that down how do
you make it actually break something
more or less question i think can be
answered
if you can give two circuits that are
not equivalent then it's very easy to
distinguish their obfuscation right you
just
um you just query on the point where
they're not equal
right so this is why you have to use it
but why do you have to verify that
they're both
that they are um yeah i think what
what chaffey think the reduction can be
not universal like that the reduction
can know that they're the same somehow
right
and therefore like it seems the
intuition is like if you have like this
meta reduction that works
but maybe you can have a proof that
doesn't use that so it sounds so i'll
say a little more
i think you know yael and others also we
try to formalize this together and we
failed but uh but like the intuition is
that the reduction should work if the
circuits are equivalent
and it should not work if they're not
equivalent because that's trivial for an
adversary to distinguish
somehow the reduction works in one case
but not in the other case
it seems like it should be
distinguishing the two cases
um but again it's not you know we can't
prove it formally
it's very tantalizing because i think
and i just wanted to say something about
that question about how do you why do
you keep working on something that seems
like
waste of time i think most of these
results almost all of them
in addition to trying to do what yael
pointed out they also did something else
so maybe they they they they
the obfuscation was the
ultimate goal but they actually had a
side result so to be
it's nice to say that having an
observation is good enough but
unfortunately program committees don't
think this way
so so and you know especially as a young
person to keep on working on something
that nobody actually seems to
give you credit for is not
it's not advisable uh in some sense so
so but
i think that all of these results have
had side results so
even though there's sort of the spy in
the sky there was also
intermediate results and and those were
worthwhile on their own
yes thank you so much yeah i think this
is actually a good point maybe this is
uh also a good point in general in favor
of uh
incremental results and then and
yeah it's it's sometimes easy to somehow
say
why are we working on this problem which
uh
you know tries to uh here is this uh
thing that we knew how to do with uh i
mean a lot of works in theory right
we take this thing where the we knew how
to do it with m squared and we change it
into m
and uh it's very easy to dismiss these
kind of things and say
uh these are incremental but these are
actually important we will not be
if we said that uh we only
accept the paper and people would
themselves say we i'm only going to work
on the paper if it solves the mega
problem and if it's not doesn't solve it
then it doesn't matter then we would
never discover all of these techniques
and we would never get it so maybe it's
important when we evaluate
when when we evaluate papers to also
remember that
you know if a paper doesn't has a result
that's a minimum
it definitely achieves that uh there is
no upper bound to what this techniques
could be used later on
so we shouldn't say okay if the paper
proved the result and that result even
by itself is not
the great uh grand thing then yeah we
should reject it
another way to think about it is that we
are all algorithms people
right even though we call ourselves
cryptographers
what we construct are construction for
algorithm and reductions which are
algorithms
the point is the reduction is valuable
even if the
assumption is false because the
reduction is still an algorithm that has
some new insight in it
and in many of the the previous papers i
did not have side results that were
really just going straight for
io where we had other assumptions the
reduction was the important point right
that the algorithm that was underlying
the reduction in the algorithms
underlying the construction
was where there was new insight and i
think that's another thing that
i definitely think um a program
committee should look at is the you know
the novel
the the insight that's being added by
the actual algorithm and we're all
algorithms people
okay so i think i'm really i'm really
liking the discussion and
as i guess as a warning as you can
already see
we might not always be we we will try to
approximate the time schedule within an
additive factor of
five minutes or so but we i'd rather
have a great discussion than be
you know completely stick into the
schedule and so i would like to
continue to have this uh interruptions
discussions etc because
uh yeah we could all watch a recording
of the videos if
if it wasn't for that so but with that
let's uh
let's start the the three-part
sequence of one line of these works but